how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
marvel cinematic universe and lately
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios has been doing a lot of
interviews now these interviews are for
the one division series coming out this
friday
but of course media outlets and fans are
asking
kevin feige about the future of the
marvel cinematic universe
the x-men the fantastic four the new
avengers all of the things we want to
know and in this video i'll go over
all of what he said and go over marvel's
plans for the next seven to eight years
of the marvel cinematic universe in this
video i'm going to go over each new team
that is coming
when to expect them arrive in the mcu
the projects that haven't been announced
yet that are coming that you may not
know about what the entire marvel lineup
looks like and what it builds to
the villains that we're going to see and
the next avengers in-game event that is
going to be
bigger than in game itself so if you
love the mcu
this is the video for you and be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of my latest videos
so to start out there is one very
interesting comment that kevin feige
recently made a couple of days ago in an
interview
kevin feige when asked by comicbook.com
if he could tell us
when the end of phase 4 was he said no
which is very interesting because
many different projects have been
announced at this point but
kevin feige can't tell us that that's it
for phase 4. the rest is coming in phase
five
that means that there are most likely
unannounced projects coming that are
going to be a part of phase four as well
now if you missed disney's investor day
where marvel announced a ton
of new projects very quickly here are
the projects they announced
the new projects coming on top of what
was already announced for phase 4 is
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
i am groot coming to disney plus the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
armor wars coming to disney plus iron
heart coming to disney plus
secret invasion moon knight she-hulk and
the hawkeye series coming to disney plus
and captain marvel 2.
a new recap series called marvel legends
which already has the first two episodes
out about wanda and vision and
the fantastic four and on top of that we
do have some projects that were revealed
to be in development at marvel studios
projects that have not been announced
yet to the general public by marvel and
these films or
disney plus shows it's not clarified are
nova
secret warriors ghost writer the
illuminati
nomad and the young avengers so how
exactly is all of this going to come
together in marvel's plans
well there are six very important
milestones that marvel is going to go
through until we eventually get to that
avengers in-game event again
and if you're wondering if marvel really
does have the next five to ten years
planned out
yes they do and kevin feige has recently
confirmed that kevin feige recently said
in an interview to varying degrees of
specificity
it's always about five to six years out
versus what we've announced
so whatever that takes us to now marvel
studios has announced films
up to what we estimate to be 2023 so
add five to six years to that marvel
studios has planned out the mcu to about
2028
or 2029 and they're going to be many
different movies and
shows coming out from marvel studios but
again it's going to hang on six
major points and the first one of those
six major events
is the introduction of the x-men this is
going to be a huge milestone for
marvel studios fox no longer owns the
x-men properties
disney and marvel studios does and
they're now going to incorporate them
into their super successful
interconnected universe known as
the mcu the marvel cinematic universe
now as far as how the x-men
are going to be introduced and built up
all evidence points to
mutants being introduced before the
actual x-men
team some individual mutants will kind
of get their own stories
until we are eventually introduced to
the actual x-men team
and it looks like the x-men are going to
be introduced a lot sooner than we
thought
and this was revealed by the one and
only marvel studios president kevin
feige in a recent interview
in the interview he was asked this
question we know with monica rambo in
one division
her character connects into captain
marvel 2 and that series connects to
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
is one division a ramp to the revival of
x-men your planning in which he replied
in hindsight in five years if when we're
talking about everything that's happened
everything can be a ramp to everything
specifically though
yes monica and captain marvel 2 and
specifically to wanda
teaming up with doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
so kevin feige himself kind of did just
confirm that the x-men are going to
start to be set up as early on as in the
one division series
now there's a lot of speculation and
theories that we could go through on how
this actually happens and i will but in
other videos
the bottom line here is that the x-men
are going to be a huge staple of the
marvel cinematic universe and ultimately
be a part of marvel's main
plan the next huge milestone for the
marvel cinematic universe is
going to be the introduction of the
fantastic four now the fantastic four
are going to be introduced
differently than the x-men the x-men are
going to be introduced one-on-one and
then come together as a group but the
fantastic four are going to be
introduced
as a group together then periodically in
the mcu they're going to work with other
heroes and other groups randomly
now of course in the mcu it's not going
to be random it's going to be
grouped together by a series of events
but they're going to work here and there
with
different people and different groups
spider-man possibly doctor strange
bruce banner she hulk and of course some
of the x-men as well
and actually the fantastic four and one
division share
one thing in common and that is agatha
harkness in the comics not only does
agatha harkness at one point teach wanda
how to grow
and harness her powers she is also the
babysitter and watcher of franklin
richards the son
of sue storm and reed richards the
invisible woman and mr fantastic so
everything is connected the next major
milestone is going to be the next
avengers team who we refer to right now
as the new avengers
now of course there are going to be new
characters introduced that we don't know
about yet that will join the new
avengers and of course there are going
to be characters that we already know
who are going to be a part of the team
as well such as sam and bucky
hopefully the scarlet witch if
everything works out for her doctor
strange
spider-man captain marvel and hopefully
more then another major milestone is
going to be the young avengers
now at this point we pretty much know
who the young avengers team is going to
be
and it's going to get started with one
division with wanda and visions twin
boys
wiccan and speed we've seen them in the
previews already so they're coming in a
couple of days
then you have people like cassie lang
scott lang's daughter who could go on to
be stature
kate bishop miss marvel harley keener
from iron man 3 and at the end of
avengers end game there
and hopefully a few more this is going
to be huge because it's another avengers
team and they're going to take on very
different villains than the new avengers
the x-men and the fantastic four
and speaking of villains the villains
are going to be the fifth major
milestone of marvel studios we have one
major villain coming that marvel studios
has already confirmed and another
insanely huge villain that marvel has
already teased
but they haven't come out and said who
it is yet and these two villains are
king the conqueror and mafisto and of
course the ones who haven't been teased
yet
are doctor doom and galactus now marvel
already announced that king the
conqueror is going to be in ant-man
quantum mania but we have recent reports
stating that he might actually debut
in the loki series and in the loki
teaser trailer there are some easter
eggs for kang but there's also a
very huge easter egg and huge visual
for mephisto if we take a look right
here at this scene in the loki trailer
we can see owen wilson's character and
in the background there's a stained
glass portrait of what looks to be
satan and satan in the mcu is going to
be mephisto
he is the ruler of the hell realm and
the marvel world this is pretty much as
big of an easter egg as it gets for the
villain
and make no mistake mephisto is one of
the greatest
marvel villains ever having connections
to just to name a few
spider-man dr strange the scarlet witch
and
the other major villain coming dr doom
now with the fantastic four of course
comes doctor doom he's a classic
fantastic four villain but he's also a
classic
marvel villain in general and again he
already has a lot of ties of what's
going to happen within the next few
years of the marvel cinematic universe
and then of course
many different insiders have been
reporting galactus for over a year now
but he will most likely be saved for
that huge avengers in-game event that i
keep speaking about and that is going to
be
avengers secret wars now the
introduction of the multiverse and how
exactly it's going to play a part in the
mcu
is already confirming that marvel's
plans are indeed to build up to secret
wars an event where essentially the
multiverse itself
blows up and different universes collide
into one
we're kind of already seeing this with
all of the reports and rumors we're
getting for spider-man 3.
jamie foxx's electro alfred molina's dr
octopus
and of course all of the others
mentioned tony maguire spider-man andrew
garfield spider-man
kirsten dunce's mj are all going to be
coming together
in spider-man 3. and then of course we
know that the universe is going to kind
of blow up in multiverse of
madness and it looks like it's marvel's
plan to eventually have all of these
universes start to fuse
together which will eventually give us
secret
wars now in this event you combine every
single milestone that i mentioned before
the x-men the fantastic four the new
avengers team the young avengers team
even the villains get together as well
and not just the ones that exist in our
universe but the ones that exist in
other different universes
as well so you have multiple iron man
running around multiple captain america
thor multiple versions of the fantastic
four of the x-men and on
and on all of the villains team up
together and all of the heroes team up
together but
in the comics ultimately it would be dr
doom who would end up controlling the
battle world that's where we were
introduced to god emperor doom one of
the strongest and most powerful villains
to ever exist in the marvel universe and
these milestones are all going to lead
to this
one huge insanely major event
and it's definitely going to be an event
that could top avengers end game
especially with the x-men fantastic four
and all of these different versions of
characters combining into one movie
or two or three different movies it'll
definitely take two but who knows they
could even do three but this is marvel's
master plan these are the steps that
they're going to take to eventually get
to secret wars there's going to be a lot
that happens in between these events and
the handful of years that are to come
but this is the game plan so if you love
marvel and want to stay up to date on
all of this be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on anything
let me know your thoughts on all of
these different major events in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and
if you want live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you